okay breakdown is as follows
there are so far well it's a one-minute
time control tournament the times will
be adjusted according to ratings it's a
war zone rated 55 players entered so far
more could enter as the tournament goes
on 18 42 is the average rating of the
entries time handicapped ending in 30
minutes any play anybody could enter
here we go
efore and we're gonna have this capture
we are Fort Knox Fort Knox and then what
I almost smell slipped right there oh I
should have taken upon b7 come on pre
move can I catch a man pre-move Forks ah
I had b7 that would have been beautiful
hang on my bishop was in the line of
fire right there stay on this diagonal
it's a good diagonal and I don't want to
Castle kingside no way but I'm gonna
come in this direction and there could
be some nasty stuff going on soon get
out of there knight on the Queen and the
rook check Oh what do we have bishop
right here on the Queen mates and stuff
mates where the mates where the mates
kill that night in me what's going on oh
my Bishop's are good they're in a good
spot how to push the Knights around the
Knights are out of squares aren't they
sort of no I don't want to trade get out
of there don't give me a check Mike King
up go there now no I'm in a for come in
a for guy was in a fork uh-huh oh I'm
missing stuff
there's forks everywhere oh there
Forks everywhere I'm catching up on time
though they resigned back to turn with
they had Mina deadly deadly deadly fork
right there what a game to start off
with not a good game at all yes that's a
better game
Oh quick resigner give me the points six
four two
ptn are they gonna start me up they're
not firing this or not don't start oh
they are starting that was a waste of
time then fantasy fantasy variation of
the caro-kann what are they doing with
h6
they're buying time but for what now I
got a tsunami of puns coming down black
throat oh I just dropped material Knight
reposition my knight one day wants to be
where oh man that nights gonna be on a
good spot
give me the dark square Bishop take my
darks for a bishop otherwise you get
this okay that was a good block hater Oh
dark square weaknesses I got a cop I got
a block of my queen I think no let me
get some space space they can't they
can't castle and I don't want a castle
um King right here is good I think I'm
gonna be um sneaky we're gonna do dance
we're dancing a little bit with our
Queens okay hang on hang on I have a
plan actually I really do come over here
now okay now let's push finally we're
having a little fun there they're not
gonna take that pun oh I should take h6
h6
rook up and over Oh a juicy square for
the knight right here Bishop takes pawn
no oh this pond is dead after trade
Queens okay I have this covered now
what's my light-square bishop doing it's
doing nothing come here and then
okay let's trade take with the pond I
need my rooks over here I think
I want to get that pun I got him no I
don't I need more attackers time
situation uh I have to I'm gonna hide in
the corner over here with my king oh I
can't break through now that was a good
move man they got a giant blockade a
giant block ain't oh wait a second time
time time time time time just move just
move just move check sneaky stuff
where's the sneaky stuff come on
sneaky sneaky sneaky sneaky come on get
this don't make me please don't make me
just run for the hills run for the hills
run for the hills take the pond I get a
queen no give a check come back let's do
this anything just move why isn't a
clock ticking clock tick burn yes
finally I had a sack of rook to get that
like point one second after clock ha
Berta Berta Maria I got 10 the leader
has 12 there's a ton of time left 24
minutes
Oh a pass no it's not a passed pond but
it's a it's a pretty deep pond right
there my knight wants to be on f4 this
is gonna be a potential break f4 and i'm
also watched no I don't want to trade I
have a space advantage let's keep it
light squares no I don't want my knight
to get pushed around okay let's try this
oh that pawns falling he's not being
taken though he could still be taken
he's not being taken oh where you going
king watch out watch out it's watcher
pun
okay my Knights scared away this is
could be falling its falling it's
officially dead get out of there Knight
okay I'm looking for a pin on the knight
soon this guy's gonna drop or is
a knight right here should've just taken
that or maybe Bishop right here is a
good idea pins this is the pin I was
talking about and I could queenside
castle but I'm not going to I think my
king is better off right there and
you're having this finally I'm on that
night twice there's also a pin coming up
oh I got the Queen in this and checks
coming up pretty move on the night
there's got to be a mate real soon
that's mate fact determined 1818 and a
bunch of 12s okay
let's go here Zeus first playing against
Zeus here this is an uphill battle every
time
Oh or is it zeus resigned I didn't know
that was possible and it knows Zeus
resigns okay I'll take them though I'm
gonna take the points if you throw the
point to me I have any choice if you
resign right okay let's go let's roll
with hitting the Queen and then getting
a pawn in the center that's not a pawn
it's another bad pre move or attempt at
it
there's your d6 no there's pressure on
this guy let's trade a little bit maybe
I could get this e5 move in now okay
they're gonna queenside castle this is
uncomfortable expand boo the Queen's
might close to dead the Queen is real
close to dead right here next move the
queen is dead Bishop takes Bishop needed
uh
I'm being sneaky the knight could be
taken take the bishop and then take the
knight
oh they had it but they missed it the
queen is dead now and so too is the pawn
okay my queen is not gonna get trapped
that Knight has to find a new home and
then I get this guy oh my do i I want to
get that guy
my Queens gonna get kicked away forks
forks forks everywhere okay
and now just get developed here okay and
more trades actually I don't take like
that I get this which is me they missed
that and I almost missed it as well
rook takes wasn't with check don't let
your clock tick okay back to tournament
35 2020 okay let's roll here French
winnow are or not alright my night could
be pinned there might be d5 d5 still
nope and now where is the night gonna go
after I push here it's threatened oh
there it goes that's a good spot let's
watch over this and okay well that
LightSquared Bishop is very strong okay
oh that could be taken I'm gonna castle
though if I took there's gonna be Queen
take I'm on this point I should have
dropped that I have this though I'm on
the bishop if the bishop backs up I take
the knight or something no what the
bishop backside will play to a six I
want to get over here I'm gonna get here
pin look at my Brooke I still want to
get that night okay take here and then
pin that night right here checks are on
Queen right here is available and I
think I have it pawn push I take this is
a good tactic check here and keep this
connected I actually grabbed this pond
even dropping this I want to get that
guy
now next stage get this guy going past
pawn the F pawn needs to get going let's
go have pond King position I should have
went with let's do it now before the
rook gets active and again and time is
on my side in this game let's give a
check undermine these the structure I
could give a check with my rook
come over here and to do what next okay
time is okay now everything should be
all right okay I could do this and still
win I think that Knights gonna hunt down
this pond and then it's a one King and
pawn in game just trying to shoulder the
king a little bit and then my pawn could
run to Victory Lane victory lane can't
be caught no time back to tournament
49-42 the big bad wolf this is the guy
that beat me in that previous tournament
the big bad wolf is gonna be out to get
me temple gainer I'm on the bishop let's
play d4 oh let's play d3 oh how is
development finished now a nasty pin
coming up on this knight the bishop is
nowhere oh wait there's sneaky stuff
here there's Bishop takes pawn I missed
it tactics everywhere now it's not
available I can recapture the bishop
there was an opportunity there for a
tactic the Queen side is shut off why
did I do that I'm gonna get trapped here
but I think it should still be alright
they're not gonna take my bishop they're
gonna take my night and then trap my
bishop that's alright I'm gonna open up
the F file because they don't have
development on the Queen side I can
actually do this I think I might
actually still be better here I want my
clean to come out and then my bishop and
then this pond is so valuable right here
hang on I don't want have to do that but
I'm gonna do it move move move move move
I have a Queen check as well I'm gonna
do it and take that bishop and then the
rook is in trouble
oh no the Queen has to block let's play
here looking at h2 next I'm gonna take
my pawn it's with check this is a big
problem they can't get completed with
their development it's hanging at this
pawn bishop check the bishop could play
two eights free
darn it I should have allowed that okay
I got to do this I guess why do I allow
that ah I should just play Bishop d6
tell this pawn push and I got the night
okay that's it's important actually I
could trade Queens and then push you
know I can't do that okay they're down
on time back to tournament 65 56 56
who's this
okay there's six there's so much time
remaining in this tournament still 16
minutes and change okay let's keep this
close I have a space advantage and I
just dropped material okay I didn't
actually if they took that that's
probably a bit crazy because it's a very
important minor piece to have around so
I can't castle otherwise there's a pawn
push let's see what black is gonna do
about that move okay and I guess I have
to play here something there might be
Knight g4 stuff okay now I could safely
castle and my knight wants to get to c6
no oh no oh no that was almost the Adobe
Flash game that right there I actually
had the option that time to not allow it
to beat me up for lack of better words
on the night okay c6 here we go I'm on
e7
I get this and then that would have been
bad the adobe flash gambit something you
never ever ever wanna have to see
let's go pawn push let's do it let's
open shop here blow this open here uh oh
this is brutal this is it mean to the
rook has to block just move here we go
back to tournament 83 72 71 I was behind
there for just a second Roberto Maria 15
minutes in change
Primo's Primo's I have to disable the
right mouse-click
I said that once before and I think it's
gonna have to take another one of those
mishaps before I actually do it okay you
could take the night I want the dark
square bishop though okay it's opening
up and I was ready to drop the piece
just then
okay maybe take my night still double
pawns are in the problem okay now I
think the big problem is for black
getting ready to get the Queen the queen
is dead dead Queen she's she's she's
dead resigning yes back to tournament
103 a bit of an extension right here 103
72 71 who is this okay French the French
defense okay we're here before why don't
we break that pin
let's take here I'm gonna take my knight
okay now they have to find a new home
mm-hmm chase that bishop away castle
maybe get in this right here coming up
bishop right here I should have played
if I did that then I would play here or
something okay get out of there you're
gonna take my knight
get out of there night
okay let's trade bishops I want to get
my knight where where's my knight wanna
be whoa
okay let's say I get in the center see
six the night can't be tolerated they're
right here or this actually if rook c8
there's a nice pond move oh this is made
that's a help me I'm gonna take the
helpmates 123 90 they were doing that to
stop a pond push they missed Queen see 6
123 1984 let's roll here see 5 6 ok d4 I
want to control d4 can I make that
happen
where's Knight f3 ok I have that under
control now it's not enough time to get
that move in or is there ok well it's
this and I guess trying it in B 5 or a 6
B 5 I had the night oh yeah
getaway night I had the night uh I still
have the night there we go
Forks after I'm out of the pin there's a
for coming up they might miss it Forks
on e2 for Connie - it's their free Queen
resign uh-oh they're not resigning get
that night out of there get out I hit
the rook and then come to a nice post
right here capture towards the center
unless you have a good reason not to the
same thing with this actually there's no
good reason not to it's a trade but this
file open up
welcome exchanges if there's files
opened up or if you want to welcome
exchanges have the files open up that's
what I meant
so what do we have my Bishop's in a good
spot checks to open this open this
captures captures I'm on the pond oh
there's sack and everything are they
they're down on time 143 110 uh-oh the
big bad wolf here he is wolf man
this is the guy in second place and he's
the one that gave me a beating last time
ah was i running for the hills
in that game okay what do we have this
is the Dragon Queen b6 oh this is a good
variation right here is this working
mm and this is this is a good variation
oh okay we're gonna go into an ending
end game I don't know if that was um the
right thing to do for my opponent I was
there was something good I think that
they had what do I have here my bishops
gonna get hit I gotta get rid of that
Bishop and then I get my king up pawn
push is probably very good okay that was
missed now this is a potential target
and let's go here my rook is maybe
running out of squares I got to preserve
that and rook right here and oh boy this
is trouble just a single square I want
to be able to come over here my bishops
gonna get kicked away the big bad wolf
has me on the ropes again the big bad
wolf um I'm losing to the wolf man oh
I'm a dead man
I'm a dead man right here oh my a dead
man or what I need time burners Oh am I
getting mated ah there's a perpetual at
the very least are they gonna go for
perpetual they should go for a win come
on you're up material check why did I
give check there let's just trade a
little bit they're gonna take that how
much time do they have time sneaky
they're being sneaky can I win this
still look at the time situation run run
run run run run run again give a check
come on
that's all I have against the wolf man
ever is time no no no no don't let it
don't let it be don't let it be oh I'm
checking my home with 0.1 seconds
oh no the Wolfman got me oh that was
painful point one seconds ah man why
can't I beat the wolf oh man I gotta get
what Oh
I'm floundering right now I'm
floundering I'm making moves right here
but I don't even know what they're doing
oh seven point one seconds let let them
have like twenty seconds but never ever
ever let my opponent just a point one
when they beat me anything with that may
in one that's the only way I can redeem
myself what am i doing
I'm floundering really really bad right
now I better win this if I could somehow
still win the tournament and I mean it's
still possible and everything but Oh
talk about a painful painful painful
lies right there you don't want to ever
have to deal with that avoid that pain
at all costs ah man the rook is
sheltered out of the game and so is the
bishop ah how do you recover from that
like playing I want to play anymore
check check mates mate I'm gonna take it
back to tournament 161 Wolfman is right
here in third
I might get paired up with him again ah
sorry I probably got really loud for
that one too but what can you do
come on you tell me how would you react
the last one point one seconds I was
clearly beat in the position but I
wanted the clock win where was the clock
win when I needed it
Oh let's go 93 f5 ok my LightSquared
Bishop is gone castle f5 ok this is a
good square f7 my Knights gonna get
kicked away where is it ok let's go here
and connect these Knights beautiful
squares I'm gonna do this
get out of there tonight I want to get
to h7 uh-oh uh-oh don't you dare move
Knight bad things happen if you move I
mean it's ok if you move but just know
the problems that you'll be faced with
look up and overs ok check and let's
take this and then come back and pin the
night I want to avoid the Queen exchange
I want my rope to come to e6 if the
Queen takes um let's support that night
oh he's gonna be on a fantastic square
let's let's do this No Oh about that
let's do this ok there now it's coming
together they don't have any time as
well man why can't I get a perfect
tournament I want to have all wings not
these speed bumps
the big bad wolf is back in second he's
not going away
ok now he's on second Sheldon 2,300 I
could fall back here very easily close
shop ok now maybe f5 or not well that's
not and say we did
No ok and then uh Oh Oh trouble right
here big trouble big trouble be sure I
want to cry get out of there Bishop I
need to run away here and then here when
the pawn pushes this is collapsing very
quickly
I want to get a Knight to d6 can I have
that happen
I guess I could do that still Knight
takes pawn is available not anymore I
don't know what that's doing I'm gonna
do it okay right here Bishop check our
bishop block I mean hit a rope hit the
Queen next time situation what's the
time what's the time what's the time
take the pollen or something
guard this guy hit that night away
double rooks I want to hang into my
bishop
oh they're insisting on it they're so
persistent is this working
Queen takes rook Queen takes rook was
their defend please defend I could oh
wait wait wait wait wait this is mate
this is mate this is me is it me oh I
might have it they're gonna resign their
clock is ticking clock ticking they
resigned back to tournament 201 197 tea
masters right there ah I gotta get this
three minutes and change you could do it
yes a quick resigner 211 197 I need to
get another one in two maybe
link h 2 h 2 where are you Oh
declined I don't want that don't give me
any of that here let's go Knight g4
Knight g4 h2 is under fire I'm coming
after h2 let's go fishing poles take the
night he's free he's never taken any
more I think I've played it so much when
there's a night that could be taken just
by default nobody takes it ok I'm still
on it
h2 hang on how they gonna recapture with
the pun take what the pond no I don't
know I don't even have the Queen am i
doing I'm gonna take the Queen just
to make sure of things what's the clock
situation I have some material my King
needs to play here or no that's the one
move I wouldn't want to see ah that's
the one move you don't want to see when
you're in a pre move let's come over
here weasel around in this direction oh
that's another pre move my Brooks is
gonna get active though right
or is it very good defense let me get
that pawn maybe can I get that pawn over
here let me get this guy come on
what's the clock situation I gotta win
this come on give a check pins pins pins
pins pins pins the bishop can't move the
bishop can't move
I got a queen the queen is on the scene
check Oh take a look I should have
pushed the pun just there flying
give me that rook 9.2 let's go let's go
let's go overrun puns run Forrest go go
go go go go go go let's go push push
push push push over here
no stalemates no stalemates push push
Queens Queens Queens checks pre-move am
I gonna win on time
I just want to bring their time time
burners where the time burners
don't-don't-don't that was almost a
repetition I got it
I was hold my breath again 231 one
minute left I think I have it even if
that guy gets 20 points let me just try
for a quick win 231 okay let's go here
Knight over here g3 over here f3 pin
this Knight and then get out of this pin
real quick oh oh they're in a pin we get
that high I'm on that pond mmm take it
with the Queen take it with the Queen
okay that would have been a deadly fork
okay pins pins the rook has to come up I
want to open this up oh this is a
problem I'm up a full rook 23 seconds
they can always let the clock tick
what's the scoop here you're gonna get
that
take my rook come on this is time to
resign you know it is you're down a rook
yes they resigned just in case
Oh with five seconds left to 51 can I
win still get another one in no first
I'm gonna take it though Oh first-place
confetti yes good games all 251 217 I
had a bunch of resign errs I don't know
if I would be right here without those
quick resign errs oh man tight game
right there